I'm also smoking crack at this point too
when I was tired umle there's a few
layers there it's layered you got to be
doing one to do the other so hold on I
got to say this I'm G to be honest with
you if smoke a crack got you out of your
Michael Jackson face there's a silver
line kep me in it for as long as I I
don't know I don't know if it got me in
or it got me out it did get me it did
help me through the Whitney Houston pH
as well say that because when she died I
had a went Houston face and when she
died I was like nearing the retirement
of my Michael Jackson career I was
processing her death and then like 2
months later my uncle died and then I'm
hanging up the glove so like there's all
these moving parts and I'm on
crack I'm 16 I'm like why won't anybody
help me sounds like
nightmare the Honeydew with Ryan
[Music]
zler